President Trump is not letting GOP
criticism deflect him from imposing
tariffs on u.s. steel and aluminum
imports House Speaker Paul Ryan says he
is extremely worried about the
consequences of the president's plan
other Republicans want to stop the
tariffs altogether
chip readers at the White House with the
latest on this chip good morning
well good morning White House press
secretary Sarah sander said the
president doesn't have to agree with the
House speaker she said the president is
committed to imposing these tariffs as a
matter of national and economic security
and a fulfill a campaign promise to
protect the steel industry no we're not
backing down President Trump doubled
down on his pledge to slap steep tariffs
on steel and aluminum imports alarming
Republicans who fear a trade war that
could wipe out economic gains I don't
think well the president dismissed that
prediction Republican leaders in both
houses are exploring ways to block or
scale back the tariffs if the president
follows through nobody ever wins trade
wars Arizona Senator Jeff Flake trade
wars are only lost by all involved and
the president continues to treat trade
as a zero-sum game in a rare public
split House Speaker Paul Ryan's office
said they were urging the White House to
not advance with this plan our country
on trade has been ripped off by
virtually every country in the world
whether its friend or enemy everybody
the president says the tariffs will help
rescue the steel and aluminum industries
but a study released Monday predicted
they would lead to a loss of nearly a
hundred fifty thousand jobs the proposed
tariffs would primarily hit longtime US
allies Canada Britain Germany South
Korea and Japan the European Union has
said it will retaliate by taxing
American imports president Trump said
he'd respond by slapping tariffs on car
imports from the EU if they want to do
something we'll just tax their cars that
they send in here like water president
Trump also spoke with Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau about trade
yesterday Trudeau's office says he told
the president he has serious concerns
about these tariffs on steel and the
John chip from the White House thanks so
much chip